i have got to thank tank's good news for
this one
i just love tanks good news so much and
check
out this six-year-old skater from
australia she recently put on her party
dress
and dropped straight into a 12-foot
ball paige tobin has been skating since
she was three
and she wants to go to the olympics one
day we cannot wait to cheer you
on page i know exactly where you're
going and it's straight to the olympics
we get to meet you today though even
more importantly i called the producers
i was like you guys have to look at this
girl she's so amazing and guess what
she's here paige tobin and her mom emma
hi
oh my god it is so great to be able to
say hi to you
we have seen you do a 12 foot drop but
is it true that you might have even done
a taller one
than that yeah i've done 14
foot and um when i
drop in it feels like i'm flying
oh like you're flying i mean i
was blown away when i saw
your video now how did you
come into the world of skateboarding did
you see something somewhere
was it in the neighborhood like what
opened your eyes to even try
skateboarding
she was only three when she started so
when she's asked if she remembers when
she started she doesn't remember
can i ask you a question if other people
are scared
of things what would you tell them
i'd say don't
never give up
i'm i i can't even imagine by the way um
i just got a skateboard
instructor to start teaching my daughter
all of
paige um she's gonna be nine and um
do you have any advice for her um
never give up yeah
so you wanna go to the olympics one day
yes and um if you won
olympic gold what would you say in your
speech
you should never give up
oh paige i love you so much and emma
what a great mom you are
thank you thank you paige you brave
brilliant girl my goodness thank you so
much for talking to
us today keep it up never never give up
never give up
thanks guys thank you so much
you